great thinkers of the ancient world such
as Socrates Plato Aristotle and these
stoics are of course household names
that have come to represent the ancient
Greek Legacy but this picture is usually
incomplete ancient Greece and these
thinkers to many represent some kind of
pure rationalistic or scientific
Endeavor a precursor to our own
enlightened age before it was
interrupted by the entrance of religion
and Superstition which dominated human
thinking until the Renaissance or even
the
enlightenment this image of history is
of course criminally Incorrect and
oversimplified and for various different
reasons many of these same philosophers
were also deeply involved in things that
we would call religious practice or even
mysticism and even saw that as a
superior way to reach truth than through
limited reason and human intellect in
fact ancient Greece was filled with
different kinds of what we could call
Mystical practices and mystical
experiences